lula da silva fue el presidente de
brasil entre 2003 y 2010 dos mandatos
tras los que se marchó con más de un 80
por ciento de popularidad el líder del
partido de los trabajadores apostó por
grandes programas sociales que
consiguieron sacar a millones de
personas de la pobreza además lula
también tuvo un papel protagónico en el
plano internacional apostando por el
multilateralismo mediando en acuerdos
energéticos con irán e incluso liderando
un eje de izquierdas sudamericanas con
caracas y buenos aires fue tras su
presidencia cuando empezaron a llegar
los escándalos un cáncer de garganta le
apartó un tiempo de la política tras su
regreso el partido de los trabajadores
se fue desmoronando en escándalos que
terminarían afectando le en 2016 el
ministerio público de sao paulo salpicó
a lula con la trama a la baja pto la
petrolera estatal petrobras habría
desviado dinero y entregado propiedades
a lula a cambio de contratos un proceso
judicial que le dejó sin la posibilidad
de ser reelegido en 2018 fue condenado
por el tribunal de sergio moro que
terminó siendo ministro de
bolsonaro y finalmente detenido durante
más de un año hasta que la corte
suprema- permitió su libertad mientras
tuviera derecho de apelación la última
decisión tendrá que ser ratificada por
la corte suprema en pleno si sale
adelante podrían complicarse las
posibilidades de reelección para ya ir
bolsonaro puesto que una encuesta
reciente del periódico o estado de sao
paulo aseguró que lula sigue superando
en popularidad